My idea of success is not money.
It's not, you know,
it's not getting a lot of money.
I think if that's your idea of
success, then that's great.
But it's um, I think it's not
really why we're here.
I think we're here to communicate
and to share ideas and stuff,
and I think that is successful.
Back home in New Zealand,
we have this saying, tēnā koe.
That's a Māori saying. Tēnā koe.
That's how you say hello.
And what it literally means
is "there you are".
If you're saying it to a group of
people, tēnā koutou.
"There you guys are".
So the fact that we're here,
that we're even on Earth
in the first place, I think
that's success in itself.
So, congratulations
everyone on being here.
And I wish you all the
best in your creative lives.
And on that note, cheers.
Kia ora, kia ora, kia ora.